avanza el tránsito de migrantes
haitianos o por américa en el caribe
autoridades en las bahamas se evacuaron
a unos 400 migrantes que permanecían en
un callo deshabitado mientras que otros
miles llevan semanas paradas en la costa
colombiana de necoclí al norte del país
su propósito es conseguir un puesto en
alguna de las lanchas e iniciar el tramo
más peligroso en su camino hacia eeuu
la densa selva del darién desde hace al
menos 10 años tras el terremoto
devastador cientos de miles de haitianos
miran por américa en busca de mejores
oportunidades la crisis el hobbit 19
empeoró sus expectativas el último
capítulo de este éxodo se escribió hace
algunos días atrás el represamiento de
miles de haitianos en el río en texas
una crisis que terminó en la deportación
de al menos 2.000 personas para analizar
este tema qué pasa con los haitianos
esta migración que la verdad se ha
convertido en una tragedia para ellos
quiero saludar en este momento maría no
eleva es ella es directora regional para
las américas y el caribe de onu mujeres
además tuvo recientemente de misión
haití gracias a maría por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa en france 24
le pregunto con qué se encuentran los
haitianos que fueron deportados de eeuu
en su país un país completamente
desconocido porque algunos como lo
estábamos diciendo tienen más de pues
diez años o fuera del país en busca de
una vida mejor qué pasa con estas
personas cuando regresan haití
bueno buenos días y muchas gracias por
tenerme en el programa bueno qué pasa
pasa
muchas cosas primero la falta de abrigo
la falta de habitación segundo la falta
de oportunidades laborales tercero si
quiero expresar las mujeres las mujeres
tienen ese poder transformador en haití
pero lamentablemente han sido
golpeadas por el terremoto del 2010 y
por el terremoto que fue recientemente
14 de agosto pero no nos olvidemos
también la tormenta tropical que tuvo
lugar hace 4 años o sea es es un país
muy golpeado pero sobre todo donde no
existe empoderamiento político de la
mujer no nos olvidemos que haití es
simplemente un lugar de política de
hombres solamente una mujer senadora dos
mujeres congresistas han sido electas no
hay espacio para la mujer en la política
me reuní con 50 mujeres maravillosas que
tienen una voluntad de cambiar su país
pero que lamentablemente no tienen
espacios por lo tanto necesitamos
para ese empoderamiento político para
que las mujeres alcen su voz de las
necesidades que tienen y de las
soluciones que tienen para esas
necesidades aquí es un país con
fantásticas oportunidades naturales de
exportación de productos y que se le
puede meter calidad pero lamentablemente
no está pasándose a la crisis política
está evitando que el país crezca y que
las mujeres en poder en un país es
golpeado como lo decía a sanz maría con
múltiples desastres naturales además
hablando de política el asesinato del
presidente yo en el movice también que
dejó políticamente haití en un limbo
todavía se están peleando también
sabemos que hay dificultades para
repartir esta ayuda humanitaria luego
del terremoto luego de las tormentas
cuál es la situación entonces de la
población que necesita esta ayuda a los
migrantes es que se devuelven a haití
pues no hay como muchas oportunidades en
el país y también le quiero preguntar
cuál es la situación de las mujeres y
niñas que se devuelven a este país que
usted bien lo decía no hay oportunidades
de ningún tipo
bueno el primer problema es la seguridad
la seguridad en este momento en haití
nunca ha estado tan deteriorada y son
grupos armados que responden a
fracciones políticas y lamentablemente
se ha vuelto un negocio el negocio de
los secuestros es sumamente peligroso y
esto es lo que está pasando y ahí se
insertan las mujeres deportadas con sus
hijos en una oportunidad de no no tienen
oportunidad tampoco de educación los
niños en este momento no nos olvidemos
que en el sur más del 60% las personas
afectadas 800.000 personas han sido
afectadas también en la educación porque
lo que ha caído más son los edificios
que albergaban escuelas entonces la
seguridad se ha convertido en un
problema muy fuerte que viven todos los
días los haitianos y estas armas estos
grupos armados no permiten que la ayuda
humanitaria fluya y ese es un gran
problema también ni siquiera en este
momento se está permitiendo que la ayuda
fluya este es un gran problema
que
ahora bien las mujeres tienen esa esa
garra como decimos nosotros en el sur
esas ganas de salir adelante por sus
hijos y por ellas mismas entonces lo que
más necesitamos es que se le respeten
sus derechos humanos sus oportunidades y
que obviamente que esa ayuda humanitaria
pueda llegar a ellas para que puedan
reconstruir una vez más su vida lo que
es impresionante de las mujeres
haitianas y su resiliencia porque es una
tragedia atrás de la otra pero en este
momento haití está sufriendo una
tragedia terrible porque no hay un
consenso político de cómo salir adelante
mariah qué más puede hacer la comunidad
internacional para realmente ayudar a
los haitianos que están en ese
territorio como lo dijimos o tan
golpeado para poder sortear esta esta
inseguridad que vive el país que no
permite que estas ayudas lleguen a ese
país
bueno mucho podemos hacer existen muchas
maneras de hacer llegar esa ayuda de
todas maneras a pesar de todos los
desafíos que se tienen no nos olvidemos
de las mujeres haitianas no nos
olvidemos de los haitianos que están
sufriendo muchísimo yo creo que lo que
más se puede hacer es procurar que se
sienten en una mesa que haya un acuerdo
político efectivo o el 11 de septiembre
un acuerdo a una sola mujer entre 20
hombres y lamentablemente lo que
necesita haití es darle espacio en la
silla de negociación política a las
mujeres las mujeres tienen que hablar
tienen propuestas tienen soluciones
mientras las mujeres sigan
totalmente excluidas de la política como
en este momento haití va a seguir en
esta situación creo firmemente que el
empoderamiento político va a llevar a un
empoderamiento económico y a un fin de
esa violencia terrible que vive el país
mariah le pregunto cómo queda eeuu luego
de hacer todas deportaciones masivas
a estos miles de haitianos que buscaban
una vida mejor en su territorio y pues
el sueño se les vio truncado cuando la
administración de presidente joe biden
pues los devolvió a su país
recientemente como queda visto en la
política internacional digamos eeuu
además recordemos también que el enviado
especial de eeuu a haití renunció en
estos últimos días por calificar esta
política inhumana de la administración
baiden hacia los haitianos que buscaban
mejores oportunidades de vida maría y
además después de pasar tanto tiempo
tratando de llegar a eeuu
yo creo en el derecho a la inmigración
es un derecho humano fundamental y el
derecho a ser tratado como una persona
digna en el respeto de los derechos
humanos es fundamental sino el mundo va
a llegar a un caos total lo estamos
viendo en varios países estamos viendo
también en europa no sólo en eeuu sino
lamentablemente también en países de
nuestra región creo que es
importantísimo llegar a acuerdos
políticos internos que permitan una
inmigración ordenada que permitan que
los inmigrantes que están en situaciones
de desesperanza por temas de seguridad
miremos los afganos cómo están en este
momento es muy importante esos acuerdos
políticos el diálogo político una
gobernanza del problema que sea
negociada y que en esa negociación como
siempre todos pierden pero al final el
mundo gana por eso es tan importante los
acuerdos políticos es tan importante el
respeto irrestricto a los derechos
humanos tratar a los migrantes con
dignidad y tratar a los migrantes como o
como seres humanos
así es y esto es algo que todos los
países debemos de mariah muy rápidamente
vamos a seguir viendo migraciones
masivas de haitianos
y yo creo que vamos a seguir viendo
migraciones de haitianos constantemente
como lo ha sabido en los últimos 10 15
años creo que esto es una realidad que
tenemos que afrontar tenemos que ser
solidarios como hemos sido con los
venezolanos no te olvides que hay más de
6 millones de venezolanos en 17 países
de américa latina yo creo que tenemos
que tener un diálogo político lo repito
para que podamos tener esa inmigración
ordenada para que podamos darle esa
solidaridad a los hermanos haitianos que
tanto necesitan pues mariah gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 y como le dijo
usted pues todos somos humanos todos
necesitamos ser tratados con respeto con
cariño y con dignidad porque todos somos
dignos de un buen trato maría gracias
por estar con nosotros buen día
muchas gracias por tenerme buenos días
estábamos conversando con maría noel
baeza directora regional para las
américas y el caribe de los mujeres y
también estuvo recientemente en una
misión en haití